en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo dibujar
las estructuras de puntos de moléculas
que tienen únicamente enlaces covalentes
simples pero en este vídeo vamos a ver
cómo dibujar esas estructuras de puntos
pero ahora para moléculas que tienen
enlaces dobles o triples entonces al
igual que en el vídeo pasado lo que
hacemos es buscar en nuestra tabla el
carbono que está en el grupo 4 o sea que
tiene 4 electrones de valencia girando a
su alrededor y tenemos 2 carbonos
entonces si nos lo ponemos por acá
y luego queremos poner los hidrógenos
entonces vamos a la tabla y podemos ver
que tiene un electrón de valencia
entonces tenemos que colocar cuatro
hidrógenos y pues tiene sentido que dos
hidrógenos estén con este carbono y los
otros dos hidrógenos estén enlazados con
este otro carbono y los dibujamos aquí
con sus electrones de valencia y
entonces unimos los puntos y notamos que
aquí están todos estos enlaces
covalentes simples sin embargo esto no
es la estructura de puntos de louis
correcta
ok porque los carbonos no están
cumpliendo la regla del octeto ok
podemos contar la cantidad de electrones
que están girando alrededor de este
carbono
aquí tenemos uno tenemos dos entonces
vamos 3 5 y 7 aunque ahí nos falta 1 y
pues lo mismo le pasa a este carbono ya
los carbonos les gusta comportarse como
un gas y ideal y tener o por lo menos
pretender que tienen 8 electrones
girando a su alrededor y la única forma
en la que eso va a pasar con dos
carbonos y cuatro hidrógenos es si estos
dos carbonos deciden compartir estos dos
electrones entonces este electrón se va
a mover para cada y este otro electrón
también se va a mover para acá iban a
formar otro enlace entre estos dos
carbonos ok entonces se va a ver más
bien de esta forma tenemos aquí los dos
carbonos y ahora en lugar de tener un
enlace covalente simple como el que
teníamos van a tener un enlace covalente
doble y cada uno tiene dos hidrógenos ok
hidrógenos y ahora sí si contamos la
cantidad de electrones que hay alrededor
de cada uno de los carbonos tenemos aquí
2 468 entonces esta es la estructura de
louis correcta para esta molécula que se
llama eterno aunque muchísimas veces le
llaman etileno ahora vamos con la
molécula de h2o aunque entonces tenemos
aquí un carbono con sus 4 electrones de
valencia y dos hidrógenos pues vamos a
poner un hidrógeno por aquí con su
electrón de valencia y otro hidrógeno
por acá con su electrón de valencia y
pues tenemos por aquí un oxígeno
entonces vamos a repasar cuántos
electrones de valencia tiene este
oxígeno entonces nos vamos a la tabla y
vemos que está en el grupo 6 o sea que
tiene 6 electrones de valencia
así es que pues vamos a colocar el
oxígeno por aquí con sus 6 electrones de
valencia nos faltan 2 electrones y los
voy a poner por aquí completando estas
dos orbitales y entonces empezamos a
unir los puntos para formar los enlaces
pero desafortunadamente esta no es la
estructura de puntos de louis correcta
porque ahora ni el oxígeno ni el carbono
están cumpliendo con la regla del octeto
aunque aquí el oxígeno tiene 2 467
electrones girando a su alrededor al
igual que el carbono tiene 2 467
entonces lo que va a suceder es
exactamente lo mismo que en el ejemplo
pasado que es que este carbono va a
aportar este electrón y lo va a mover
hasta que este oxígeno también va a
mover este electrón hasta acá para
formar un enlace doble con este carbono
y entonces lo que nos queda es este
carbono con un enlace doble con este
oxígeno y bueno el oxígeno tiene estos
dos orbitales llenos tienen sus dos
puntitos de este lado y otros dos
puntitos de este lado y el carbono tiene
dos enlaces con estos dos hidrógenos
y entonces podemos checar si nuestra
estructura de louis de esta molécula es
correcta contando la cantidad de
electrones que giran alrededor de cada
uno de estos átomos y aquí en el carbono
tenemos 24
8 y el oxígeno tiene 1 2 3 4 6 y 8
entonces esta si es la estructura de
puntos de luís correcta de esta molécula
que se llama formaldehído así es que
pues vamos a ver otro ejemplo
entonces vamos a ver el ejemplo de c 2 h
tenemos aquí 2 carbonos un carbono con
sus 4 electrones de valencia y otro
carbono con sus 4 electrones de valencia
y tenemos dos hidrógenos entonces tienen
sentido poner uno por acá con su
electrón de valencia y el otro por acá
aquí claramente tenemos un enlace simple
entre estos dos carbonos y entre el
hidrógeno y el carbono y el hidrógeno y
el carbono sin embargo si empezamos a
contar la cantidad de electrones que
giran alrededor de este carbono vamos a
obtener que hay a ver 12 46 aunque a
este carbono le faltan 2 electrones y lo
mismo le pasa a este carbono aunque hay
por qué estos carbonos y bueno de hecho
todos estos elementos en este nivel de
la tabla periódica quieren parecerse a
este gas noble réquiem tener
electrones girando a su alrededor y para
hacer esto pues estos dos carbonos van a
decidir empezar a prestarse sus
electrones aunque entonces estos dos
carbonos van a utilizar estos dos
electrones para formar otro enlace
porque si están enlazados eso cuenta
como si dos electrones estuvieran
girando alrededor de cada uno de los
carbonos pero bueno no va a ser
suficiente con compartir estos dos
electrones también necesitan compartir
estos electrones de aquí así es que se
están formando tres enlaces entre estos
dos carbonos aunque tenemos aquí los
carbonos y tenemos tres enlaces bueno
más bien un enlace triple y tenemos los
hidrógenos por acá
y esta es la estructura de puntos de
louis de la molécula llamada acetileno
que bueno también se llama de tino pero
para verificar que esté correcta tenemos
que contar cuántos electrones que irán
alrededor de cada carbono y son 2 468 o
sea que todo está muy bien
alrededor de este carbono gira en la
misma cantidad de electrones y bueno no
hemos verificado en ninguno de estos
ejemplos pero porque es muy trivial que
giran únicamente dos electrones
alrededor de cada hidrógeno así es que
pues ya vimos cómo son las estructuras
de puntos de louis de moléculas que
tienen enlaces simples y enlaces dobles
en las strip leds y a continuación vamos
a hablar acerca de estados de
hibridación de moléculas que tienen
carbono